hi my name is Minchin pang I'm with
warfarin and the talk now we'll give is
labeling in visualization this talk I
will cover labeling systems in foreign
language and that will include the point
curve area labelings so please come to
join me today I'm going to talk about
the labeling system in warfarin language
so actually the first line I changed to
a word without label it's kind of
dramatic but it is kind of like to show
what kind of visualizations you know
that we thought labels will feel like
because he will be some it will be like
over the information that you really
want to know and I'll talk about the
frameworks that we have in the wulfing
language for the labels you know I will
go a little bit down to the graphics
label to show you what the tools that we
have and what's the the basic stuff that
we build upon and then I will go to the
visualizations and you know the
functions the plots and the charts right
and then there will be different type of
implementations in the list plot
families and the simple plots and then
charge them more so just a quick a quick
glance on this plot it's a James Bond
movie this is the x-axis is the budget
y-axis is the u.s. box office and you
know it if you make a report you don't
really want to show the input of this
graph to your audience you just want to
show the you know to present
organizations and that you you would
hope that this visualization can can be
self-contained but with this case
without labels you know
really know what other points are so I
want to show you later that I'm going to
regenerate this example and with labels
another example is the Pokemon states so
each point represents a Pokemon and you
know the x-axis is the speed y-axis is
its weight and the 202 lines in the
middle are the mean values it looks
interesting but it would be even better
if I can show the labels and leaders
there are about like a thousand points
here so I want to show you that how
often language can generate the labels
that will give you enough of information
of how you look like
so the frameworks so on the low label
this is the tools that we build upon so
if you feel you know you want to build
your own label system this will be
exactly the tools that I have used so
the first one is the text you know text
put the expressions and coordination and
offset here I draw a little diagram here
to show you what the offset mean so if I
said that I want to put my label at a
label label position to 3 and the label
offset is minus 1 minus 1 that means I
want to line up this left button corner
at the level position so that's the text
in the graphics
another tool is inset instead is
slightly complicated but it's much more
flexible because you can put anything in
the first expressions it can be another
graphics an insect can be put in the
graphics 3d as well but what does the
syntax of it is like Lee's so this is my
label which is a graphics and the red
dot here is the object position point
five point five this is the user's
coordinate so you can see this is y and
x and y-axes both add 0.5
so you can put the label at the label
position which is again 2 comma 3 but
now I'm aligned in this object position
which is the red dot at that label
position I hope this is clear so with
this information the labels LED we
implement we implemented in these
automatic algorithms actually have 8
label positions now we put some land
means like we didn't put our labels like
you know continuously around the point
we only choose 8 positions - to locate
them so once you know this then you will
have an idea that when you see the label
you will find the closest point that
according to this system so this is one
two three four positions the other four
is 5 6 7 8
horizontally and vertically right so
that's the low-level tools that we have
and I have built upon our labeling
system but coming to the functions that
how do you use the labels we can
directly you will get the labels
automatically from the input itself if
you use the the metadata like or in this
format so as long as your meta
information is mention up the list
length of the input in this plot and
then this label the call-outs in this
case will be automatically used you can
see that I didn't specify any options
here another case is that if you use in
associations the list plot family will
also pick it up automatically or in this
case we don't want to be too aggressive
so you do need to put play labels go to
automatic for you to show up
right so that on the input label
another way to do that is to use rappers
we have labeled rapper in color rapper
right by the way this label D is the
same is the same syntax that the front
end labeled is using so they are all
unified well here this diagram I showed
it is from the documentation of call out
: has a great flexibility and here is to
show you what all the positions in the
syntax means so the position in the
call-out actually means this turning
point or we call it the label location
actually and then there is an anchor
position which is connecting to you know
the main object that you want to label
to in the position here just like
instead you can also specify which part
of this call our label you want this
neck to connect to and that system is
illustrated here the left bottom corner
is 0 0 the right at the top right corner
is 1 1 so here I want to show you that I
put the call out and right so this is a
label and the position I said to
automatic the anchor position is
automatic in this case in the plot it
will be put on the right-hand side of a
call-out so if I say that I want the
position to be ad 10 or let's start from
10
so it will find the Y positions of the
function so you only need to specify the
x position and the y position will be
found automatically but in this case it
doesn't look nice because it's colliding
with the axis so you can say that I want
it to be like that so this is still
automatic because you don't
automatically it down because you didn't
specify any y positions you are just
saying that I want to but above above
what is above the function of course you
can specify something like that right
you can specify the positions this is
looks like it is sticking with that so
but if you put it away then the Anchor
Point will be found automatically but
you you can also specify the anchor
point specifically right again you don't
need to specify it x and y you only need
to specify the X&Y will be found for the
anchor point so I'm going to down to
this detail and just to show you that
how flexible it is in the end you can
specify tons of options you see and the
positions very specifically but I have
to say that's not so different from just
using the EPI logo with text so I hope
that the default behavior that we have
found will fit most of cases that that
you will need so and I will see more I
will show you more cases later so here
is an example that I copied from the our
documentation before the labeling system
was implemented so in this case the
developer want to label these two points
so they wrote a function that that's
crafting the labels here and using the
epilogue to put the labels here right so
I'm going to show you that how we can do
that just using the labeled wrapper
so then you don't need that level
anymore this is just the points two
points and you I put the first label a
second label and the first label at X
equal to one second level at equal X
equal to two so that's that's all you
need in it or you can use the call-out
here I use the slightly complicated
position syntax to position this color
label so that's the rapper's so we have
the data of the rappers we can also use
the options to specify labels so for the
plot in its family you can specify it
playable scheduled expressions and it's
actually the same behavior of automatic
then the labels were used or pick up the
expressions you can specify so in this
case because they are two label two
functions so I specify the two positions
and they can be scaled
that's the scaled position of the the
curvatures
and this is an example to live
interactive manipulate to show you how
you can customize the look of the
call-out the syntax is like this this is
almost all the options that Co our
supports here there is something called
the leader lens leader size so here you
can extend the leader and the neck and
also the gap between the anchor point
and the position you want to label you
can road headed let me make you longer
and you can change the rounding radius
and the frame margin change in the
background right so something is the
neck angle that we have designed if you
make it automatic it's going to always
be wholly horizontal but if it if it is
set then this is going to be any
position this or any angles another
thing is the appearance this is a super
option that will give you different feel
let me fix this yes so this is a balloon
some appearance will disable some
options because late doesn't make they
don't make sense for some appearance and
there are for example like marker oh
this one does make sense so let me go
back to the frame so that circle you
know just to give you a flavor that how
rich this can be and here is a gallery
of the car labels we generated for the
marketing page
right okay
so now I'm going to talk about the
different implementations in various
plots the first one is the plot family a
use case in here is the multiple curves
so the scene I want to point out is that
we have very various label in positions
that you can use but it will really
depends on the applications so I will
just to show you you know a gallery of
them so I hope that you will find
something useful for your application so
this the first one is the multiple
curves sometimes you do have lots of
curves in the plot and it's the labels
which is done here is going to avoid
colliding to each other by using fine
minimum and all you need to do is
specify play labels go to automatic you
can also specify the position of it in
this position it is a named position
which is automatically chosen the actual
positions for you so in this case this
is above this is above the overall curve
this is scaled 85 percent right you can
also do multiple labels they do need to
match up though so here is that I have
two labels here and I have two set of
positions this is first one and this is
a second one on this absolute x and the
other one is the - absolute x you can
also use labeling to label a feature in
this example it's the exclusions so this
is right this is an using the color
rapers on the input
right I will leave that more for you to
explore so like I said that was just
examples on the plot it can work on the
log plot log log plot and if you specify
scaling functions on the plot it will
just work fine on the list plot families
their similar behavior for this case
because it does look like a line well
because it is connected in this case we
put the labels also on the right hand
side well but the automatic takes is not
going to show you anything because
there's no expression there and this is
where we come to the interesting cases
cases that that is when the input data
is actually points and you want to label
the each point so how do we handle this
case we use our deal with the algorithm
we use is something called the point
feature labeling problem so we try to
find the positions for each point so
that the labels can avoid in I can avoid
the curtain the collisions into each
other and also the points so we get
lucky that in this case there's no too
dense the area so we need to drop the
label but it is possible when you have
very dense the points cluster there's
just no position for some points that
you can find you know a location to put
the label that it doesn't collide in
that case we will just drop the label
and provide the tour tip for you right
so this is the example I showed in the
first slide which is the James Bond
movie so it gives you more context in
the plot itself you don't need to you
know show the input because sometimes
the input can be a little bit
intimidating but I hope it is not to you
because I'm simply just using the
call-out on the date herself
it doesn't really need to use this pure
function but you know using entities and
a list of the properties is just
fetching the data much faster right
I'll show you lad I don't really need we
just use this string I can use the
images of it and well string image
graphics anything we will find the size
of it and we will run into the algorithm
to avoid the collisions so it's the same
thing yeah this case is the Pokemon
States this is the example I said about
there's too much points too many points
in the dense the area that leaves no
position I can put the labels we saw
colliding but the labels that I put
there don't collide each other so that's
the point and here I even use the
tooltip on each point so you can see you
know the Pokemon character there we saw
the labels and all these tooltip this
plot is probably you know you probably
would take two seconds to to to look at
it but with more context and you know
labels here this plot becomes an
exploration tool right charts we have
supported labels in charts from version
7 when the charts were created we had
the chart labels labels using the
call-out is something that we supports
we supported since version 11 I think
and the first thing that we supported is
on the bar chart so in this case that
they are quite some amount of the data
and we really want to show the labels
previously you know people are putting
the labels on the axes then they have
rotated so this vertical so it is you
know line you know lying down on the air
is vertically so you have to like what
hit your hair to see it but now you can
just use the call-out and then it will
automatically put the labels on top of
it and in a nice format this looks like
the timeline plot is the same similar
fashion we can spike it up we put the
scaling function and we rescale the size
of the labels to emphasize which company
has higher GDP so this makes it much
easier to read this may not be the best
example to put in the pie chart but I'm
just to show you that what does the pie
chart do if I just put the same data
straight in so this is the result at the
first glance it probably is not so
impressive but if you took a closer look
you will see all the labels are not
colliding each other and they are
avoiding by using the high minimum again
so this is some features that a lot of
customers have asked so here it is right
the last example is to use I wanted to
show the Bible Chapel I saw that you
know using the Geo bubble chart is more
impressive in the same purpose so here
is some the petroleum production in the
world and icarly I only showed the first
25% which still a lot right and this is
the result which is a geo bubble chart
and they are the size of the labels is
relative to the amount of petroleum the
country produce and the labels are the
country names there are some cases like
these two bubbles they are they are
in a very dense area so we couldn't find
the labels to put them without
introducing any ambiguity so that's how
that's why we didn't put the labels
layer but right as long as there is a
position that we can put the label
without making it ambiguous then we will
do so so that's the fancy example I
showed it here that will conclude my
talk thank you very much
[Applause]